so in his remarks today which once again
were 25 minutes late because you know
joe biden was busy
the president vowed to quote hunt down
those responsible for killing 13
americans today in kabul in a matter of
days it seems like we've gone from
withdrawing to being pulled back in to
war mitch mcconnell for example the head
republican in the senate just tweeted
this the president needs to clearly and
firmly state the united states will stay
as long as it takes in afghanistan
well that's an interesting response
you're hearing a lot of that by the way
unfortunately from a lot of republicans
on capitol hill this proves that we need
to stay in afghanistan what to make of
this jessie kelly is the host of the
jesse kelly show he joins us tonight
jesse thanks so much for coming on
you're watching this what what do you
think that
what do you think this means what is
going on here exactly
politics no patriotism at all no love of
country at all this is all politics
tucker that's why i um i'm as full of
hate and rage right now as i have been
probably since 9 11.
i know for a fact either mothers or
wives or somebody like that they're
getting a phone call tonight or we'll be
getting a phone call shortly and they're
going to find out husband's never coming
home again daddy's never coming home
again my son's never coming home again
and i know for a fact the scumbags in
the white house who run this country
they're sitting around a table as we
speak and they're not worried about
mommy they're not worried about daddy
not worried about that kid they haven't
shed a single tear for anybody they're
worried about poll numbers tucker the
word what what polls well how are we
doing with middle-aged women how do you
think we did with black people tonight
how do you think we did these people
disgust me they disgust me as much as
the taliban disgust me i'm so grossed
out by the people who lead this country
our warriors deserve so much better they
certainly do
i gotta say though it does feel like
potentially a turning point i mean this
reveals such rot underneath
our credential class
you know their claim to power is their
expertise they're good at stuff you're
not what do you know you're jessie kelly
used to sell rvs shut up and obey
but they've just revealed that they
actually have no idea what they're doing
they can't even withdraw from
afghanistan
so
what change do you imagine going forward
this will spur
absolutely nothing that absolutely
tucker they put joe biden in there on
purpose you remember they cleared out
the field to put in this old man who's
clearly half functional instead of
dependable we got depends in the white
house the guy has no idea what he's
doing and the backup plan is kamala
harris who quite literally laid down to
get the job we these people don't care
about country at all there's no plan and
that's what's amazing right now tucker
none of them not one person not lloyd
austin or millie or any one of these
idiots none of them are looking in the
mirror as you and i are talking and
saying to themselves gee i think i
really screwed up they're all worried
about their own rear ends and their
pensions in their career and there's no
patriotism anymore and it makes me want
to vomit
well lloyd austin at the height of this
two days ago reminded us that the real
threat is not the taliban it's white
supremacy in america it's trump voters
said that out loud
no yeah him and miller was on in front
of congress you remember testifying
about white rage and how he wants to
understand white rage well we're finding
out right now what all that's getting us
there are only so many hours in the day
either you're digging into white rage or
you're digging into actually finding a
way to ex-fill your people from
afghanistan without getting american
citizens slaughtered brave marines
slaughtered our allies slaughtered this
is more than just a national
embarrassment this is an international
embarrassment i can't even imagine what
the military planners in china are
pouring into the ears of xi jinping
right now because i have to be honest if
i were them i'd be landing on the shores
of taiwan tomorrow knowing we have a
half dead person in the white house
yeah you might if you lived in taipei
you might want to be buying lots of
bitcoin and picking up a condo in santa
monica i would say uh right about now
jesse kelly thank you so much for that
good to see you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else